between 2005 and 14 only 39% of top
films or actually original the other 61%
or sequels prequels remakes retelling
spin-offs or adaptations Hollywood loves
taking what's already popular a book - a
story or another movie
copying and pasting and then swimming in
money the same stories told over and
over and over again and don't get me
wrong a good movie is a good movie
sequel or not but then there's paul
blart - mixed reviews let's say of
course Studios like duplicating their
success but first and foremost Studios
like profit so why not make what people
want less unnecessary sequels and more
original stories Hollywood is so
repetitive not because it's run out of
ideas or lacks creativity but because as
always money
the problem with movies is that there
are huge upfront investment with a crazy
amount of risk it's a business of big
winners and Bakke losers like a hundred
and forty million dollar losers man
these are some really uncanny valley
faces in fact every other movie fails to
make a profit but those you never hear
about probably why they failed the ones
you do hear about are the top six
percent making half of all the profit
the saying in the industry is nobody
knows anything not a comforting thing to
hear when deciding where to put a
hundred million dollars sometimes it
looks more like gambling than investing
there are just far safer places to put
your money like anywhere else okay
almost anywhere else so there might be
demand for more original stories but
with this much money even a little risk
is a lot of risk Steven Spielberg
predicts it would only take a few high
budget films to fail for the entire
industry to change forever
so Studios optimized for every cent that
they can
[Music]
it's been almost a decade since James
Cameron released avatar or Titanic with
blue people avatar tells the story of
Dances with Wolves in space in order to
further a director's already fast ego
and to advance movie technology further
in the wrong direction and it's still
the most profitable movie ever by a good
margin but let me ask you how much do
you actually remember I'm willing to bet
it doesn't really hold up for all the
excitement and boy was there a lot of it
it just doesn't have anywhere near the
influence of a Star Wars or Avengers or
Harry Potter so why was it so successful
obviously a lot of it was this and this
which now less impressive makes me a
little skeptical about the four sequels
planned until 2025 hey you do you James
but what avatar got really right was
wide appeal there are four big
demographics in the film industry men
and women under 25 and over 25 making a
really successful movie it means
targeting all of them think it's Star
Wars Indiana Jones Hunger Games at
Jurassic Park
everything from Pixar these four
quadrant movies are the dream of every
studio huge audiences huge sequels and
lots of merchandise but because so many
movies try the same strategy they end up
following the same pattern lots of
action and adventure very obvious good
guys and bad guys and a steady stream of
simple humor ideally at least one
character each quadrant can relate to
young and old relatively speaking men
and women but one demographic is
especially important teenagers AMC was
so desperate to attract them they
thought hey kids can't get off their day
in telephones let's just allow texting
in our theaters which luckily didn't go
so well and because teenagers generally
like seeing a little more than talking
rodents Studios like to avoid GE and PG
movies are is usually too limiting which
puts pg-13 right in the Goldilocks zone
these four characters can make or break
a film 41% of movies are rated pg-13 and
they make half of all the profit which
makes sense the industry itself created
the rating after parents took their kids
to Temple of Doom or gremlins and
weren't so happy
remember that microwave scene yet
also and while youtubers censor
themselves to avoid getting demonetized
Hollywood kinda does the opposite a nice
wholesome story in danger of getting too
soft a rating it might sprinkle in some
swearing or violence pushing themselves
into golden pg-13 territory and there
may be rules about marketing these to
children but movies like Avatar show
they don't really matter just sell your
characters to toy companies who
technically aren't advertising the film
itself so who's in charge of ratings who
determines the success of your years and
years of hard work and multi-million
dollar investment in the u.s. you have
two options
send your movie to the Motion Picture
Association of America where you don't
know whose rating what their
qualifications are and don't have any
recourse or don't get shown in 99% of
theaters monopoly what are you talking
about their mission is to protect the
creative and artistic freedoms of
storytellers just not independent ones
or anyone making what they don't like
they may have been reading a bit too
much Orwell when they wrote that oh and
don't think the ratings actually mean
much pg-13 movies actually have more gun
violence than those rated R and the
shenanigans don't stop here the dream of
any big company is to own everything if
you're an oil company you want to find
oil drill for oil transport the oil
refine the oil and there will be blood
every company you involve it shaves off
a bit of profit until there isn't a drop
left for you which is why movie studios
used to own the theaters by controlling
the showings they could make sure their
paul blart 6 wouldn't have to compete
with someone else's avatar but then the
US Supreme Court said get out of here
you need a separation and turn the
industry inside-out what was one
industry became too intertwined with the
goal of weakening the studio's but
seventy years later they still have all
the power because they don't need any
one theater to make a profit but
theaters desperately need them when you
buy a ticket your money is split between
them depend
on when you go at the beginning most
goes to the studio which slowly changes
over time because of this theatres
usually lose money early on and then
squeeze out a little profit by the end
but that's if they're lucky when it
comes to star wars that the force is
with Disney they can pretty much set the
rules theaters can and do get angry and
then of course they agree anyway
why does a literally 40 cent bag of
popcorn cost four dollars because it's
the only money they don't have to share
sometimes their only profit and studios
make such a big deal about opening
weekends because that's when they make
most of their money but exactly how much
is hard to say because when a studio
starts making a movie it forms a new
company gives it the budget and then
pulls a clever bamboozle it can say hey
new company you owe us some fees take
most of its money and make the movie
look unprofitable Harry Potter and the
order of the Phoenix made four hundred
and fifty million dollars but when
workers reached out their hands the
studio said so sorry but there's just no
money to give the movie isn't profitable
how does a Harry Potter movie lose a
hundred and sixty-seven million dollars
clever accounting the studio took a
total of three hundred and fifty million
dollars in fees plus the film's budget
is only a fraction of its total cost
marketing alone can cost just as much
plus manufacturing and overhead and so
on most profit is made not domestically
but internationally and after theaters
studio squeezed as much as possible from
DVDs pay-per-view cable TV merchandise
video games and music the industry may
not be sustainable companies like movie
paths are trying to save it by offering
unlimited movies for ten dollars a month
but let's say you see a normally ten
dollar movie every day for a month - the
ten dollar subscription and they've lost
two hundred and ninety dollars just on
you just in one month if the business
fails we'll all be conditioned to
unlimited movies and may not like going
back to the old prices but as sites like
Netflix and Amazon rise from the ashes
things will probably change for the
better
anyone can watch their favorite movies
from home or actually make them
themselves seriously if your dream is to
make films or YouTube videos that's
something you can just start learning
and Skillshare is the place for this
with video courses taught by the experts
you can learn writing from a New York
Times bestselling author so you can make
the most interesting videos possible you
can start drawing a beautiful movie
poster or illustrations for your video
from a course like this one when you're
ready to start filming you can practice
shooting and editing this one teaches
you how you can get great-looking shots
even on a low budget if you're more
interested in animation you can master
After Effects with this course which
even gives you practice files you can
download and follow along with they have
over 20,000 classes I was amazed to find
out the other day they even have some on
cooking and learning languages a premium
membership gives you unlimited classes
so you can take as many as you want and
the first 500 people to use the link in
the description and get two months
completely free thanks a lot to skill
share and to everyone who gives it a try
[Music]